Comfort ikata san jarrett was just 19
when he was killed the seminary student
had just walked out of a church when
soldiers suddenly appeared and opened
fire
it is that the way that it is just I'm
just confused I don't even know what I
can say so that is the only boy that I
have several eyewitnesses say they saw
Jared killed at close range
execution-style even though he was
clearly recognizable as a member of the
church the Archbishop of momenta is
calling for action but fears there will
be no response people are afraid of the
army the people are terrorized by the
army and nobody seems safe in the hearts
of the army because you are guilty in
front of them and you are not even given
a chance to tell them who you are and it
is already called extrajudicial justice
if it is justice at all execution of no
people and are quite number of such
cases security forces are visible all
over bomb Enda but we are not allowed to
film them openly nearly every resident
of this northwestern city has a story
about their violent tactics many blame
the president the body of a separatist
has been on the streets for three days
locals say it's the Army's way of
warning the population not to embrace
independence for cameroon's
english-speaking region the governor is
a close ally of President Paul Biya he
consented to meet us but only if he
received our questions before then he
rejected all but one of them complaining
of the security of discretion is under
control all over the region and we are
facing some little hot spots but those
that situation could not prevent us to
master the situation all over the region
or what they complained about whether
human rights abuses and SS I have
already asked you to that question that
the complaints you are going to address
the complaints of your mother right
in keeping with our laws a regulation we
venture out of the regional capital to
get a sense of people's daily lives and
how they're faring in these tense times
so we just left Amanda and we already
noticed that the drivers on the road are
giving each other sign so the cars
coming from the front it will tell our
car if we can continue if it's safe or
if you should be careful and possibly
stop the car we drive through nearly
empty villages whose main streets are
eerily quiet after half an hour we
reached the first separatist roadblock
with these weapons they're fighting for
their own state Amba's onea trying to
secure the people's are all individual
issues around because that means we
attack us here and kill ignore seven
people so that's why I see or see what
you can see we are mourning that and
what do you do if the military comes if
they come to attack we do once we have a
supersede the local blade that we have
we used to manage it and all can do when
it's stronger at least we'll see I can
defend myself and jump into the bush
several separatist groups are active in
the region
a few kilometers further we observe some
of them intimidating local residents as
well as people passing through they've
threatened us too demanding protection
money the village of numbaz often caught
between fronts according to a local
priest
Roland re tells us that pressure from
the separatists forced the school here
to close two years ago so he tries to
set up a kind of playground near the
church to give children a place to go
it's difficult because both parties are
not saying anything that can give you
some consolation or some hope attempt
these people have to even come around to
they're asked to pay money in a group
they can it's strange but you can find
these boys asking these people to make
some contributions to give to them to
support them and the people they are
scared they cannot do anything they just
have to give they just have to give so
now we don't know where the worse if I
were to run to the boys or to run to the
soldiers and because he was afraid you
fear is a catch word here back in bomb
Enda once the commercial center of the
region now its economy is in ruins
fear overshadows everything as a sign of
protest against the government so-called
ghost town days have been taking place
for almost two years every Monday most
people remain at home and shops are
closed it's just mobile vendors who are
coming out to do some business because
they needed to survive and many of them
told us they're still facing threats
from
protests the Archbishop of Pomona sees
no ends to the spiraling violence
without a total amnesty as Jerrod acha
acha is laid to rest the archbishop
appeals for dialogue between the warring
parties with the hope of sparing lives